hey youtubers is charlie so this week
rebels paired Ezra and ZEB up for a very
special tie fighter field trip normally
I just point out my favorite references
and do a review but I did spot a few
funny subliminal messages so I'll try to
explain that too hello any new people if
you just find me for the first time I'm
doing weekly rebels videos so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I usually
add Star Wars Episode 7 news to the
stuff whenever is happening so starting
with top five moments number five
chopper robo trolls everyone the r5
droid being an provides the call
to action that set the big Ezra Zeb
field trip into motion it didn't stop
there though later in the episode when
Canaan and Hera were chilling out
playing dejarik chopper really let them
have it like he really laid into him the
scene was a nice reference to the art 2
versus Chewbacca match in episode 4 with
the twist that chopper did not have to
let Kanan win for fear of getting his
arms ripped out of their sockets then
whenever resident Zeb came back at the
end he just doubled down on harassing
them I'm surprised that Zedd didn't
prank him with like a restraining bolt
or something troll me once shame on you
troll me twice shame on me number four
the Wookiee life dead they don't specify
how much time has passed since the last
episode but Ezra's still having fun with
Zeb for saving his life the Wookiee life
debt isn't explained really well on the
original trilogy the expanded universe
in the comics picked up the slack though
Chewbacca was rescued from an imperial
prison ship by Jung Han Solo he'd been
ordered to kill him by his Imperial
supervisor but instead free Chewie in
the other wikis it's a lot like what
happened in episode 1 of rebels when
they freed all those bookies so the
wookies have a custom that whenever they
owe their life to someone the debt lasts
until they're dead but I think their
children can also choose to honor it
under special circumstances it's nice to
see them coming together as a group but
I feel like Zeb is just too easy bait
for Ezra like he's making himself to
open he's not a full version of to back
or anything but he does fill the role in
that crew big scary alien covered in fur
and yes this is a kid show but I feel
like he would be a little bit more fun
if they just let him be scary and over
the course of the series Ezra was able
to win him over like if we just took the
entire season to win him over it kind of
seems like Zeb is wearing his emotions
on his sleeves you know ours cuffs or
whatever it is he's wearing there
under normal circumstances whatever Ezra
and chopper busted in on him sleeping
the first time I would have expected him
to just fire a warning shot at them with
a small blaster we learned last week
that his entire race was slaughtered
with a few exceptions so I'm a little
surprised that we're not seeing more
post-traumatic stress behavior number
three all for love of fruit they were
there for regular supplies which they
lost but Hera trolls him a little with
the mission to nowhere so she thinks it
wasn't her trying to be mean but it's
funny to think that everything in the
episode that happened was a result of
everyone just being kind of rotten to
each other even so being kind of made
fun of him with the graffiti in her room
in a real a subtle way I feel like it
was the show telling us that all these
characters have good hearts they just a
really really selfish if you didn't
catch it during the dejarik scene to
herand Kanan are totally doing it on the
down low they haven't had a lot of
scenes together in the last three
episodes but there are some trailer
clips with them almost kissing so you
can tell they have a relationship that
the show is going to explore at some
point Hera and Sabine or two characters
that we haven't spent a lot of time with
but they will get their own episodes per
day soon number two Ezra learns to use
the force it takes in most of the
episode to land the trick but he's able
to use some limited force telekinesis as
of now he's exhibited future
premonitions a forced push and now
telekinesis I guess you could also say
he's made some small force jumps some of
his rooftop acrobatics or a little
superhuman but this is a cartoon so they
don't always obey the laws of physics we
haven't seen him train with cannons
lightsaber yet I think that's going to
be next that and getting better at the
lesser Jedi powers they gave Zeb that
obi-wan Kenobi line this is not the
tighter you're looking for but after
some lightsaber training I think we're
going to see Ezra start to learn how to
influence week our minds the
stormtroopers on the show are pretty
dumb so they're going to be easy targets
I think of all the Jedi powers the ones
that allow you to control others are the
hardest to master so I'll be really
interested to see if they just let him
do it right away or if he has to work up
to it if they're planning some sort of
giant ezra force building moment for the
finale this year i think it probably
gonna end up being a lightsaber battle
with Inquisitor like the first time that
Luke fought Vader and got his ass handed
to him not to make too many puns Ezra is
learning to use the force but he is
light years away from being able to take
on someone as skill
the Inquisitor so if he were able to
beat him in a lightsaber match I'd be a
little bit upset in order for villains
to be a threat they have two seemed
unbeatable and my number 1 moment tie
fighter joyrides totally love them
stealing the TIE fighter did not love
all the flying through the city I get
the Zeb hadn't flown one before but I
feel like they let the moment drag on
too long like him talking to Ezra flying
alongside him through the streets while
Ezra ran on the rooftops that felt a
little bit more like a family guy gag
like if Peter were flying a TIE fighter
up and down the aisles of a grocery
store casual use of TIE fighter is a
funny concept but I feel like the joke
peaked when he was spinning in circles
blasting everyone I think they could
have just cut away sooner and use the
extra time for scene where the Imperials
punished the farmers for everything that
happened I feel like they didn't follow
that thread to the logical conclusion
like them saving the farmers I feel like
the Imperials would have just gone right
back after they left and killed them the
episode was pretty clearly trying to do
the uncle Owen and Beru episode 4 scene
with the smoldering ruins and yes it is
a kid show like I said so they're not
going to be murdering a whole bunch of
people but don't you feel like the
Imperials would just go right back after
everyone flew off Ezra and ZEB didn't
destroy their transports they just blew
up one of the gun turrets the Imperials
had more weapons and they're not the
only ones on the planet like there are
other Imperials that can help them out
part of the theme this week was that you
know taking the quick and easy way well
sometimes leave you worse off and I feel
like we didn't see the consequences of
that they had this applies but because
Ezra wanted to steal the fruit they lost
everything and even though they saved
the farmer friend the Empire is still
gonna take the farm so they didn't
change anything I know that sounds a
little bit pessimistic but let me know
what was your favorite moment and let me
know if you spotted these really big
subliminal messages though these are
just a little bit funny so I feel like
this is just a little Disney propaganda
but the first and most obvious one was
that you should eat more fruit as we're
almost got them killed because he loves
fruit so much which i think is funny the
stormtrooper even asked him you did this
all for fruit then the other big one was
when Zeb gave him the TIE fighter helmet
I mean yeah it looks really cool but I
feel like that's Disney telling you to
buy more Star Wars toys Ezra collects
toys and toys costs money a lot of money
money equals profits anytime I see
characters lusting after objects like
their toys I feel
it's merchandising for Star Wars toys in
real life think about it this way George
Lucas made millions of dollars in the
movies but he made billions of dollars
on the toys the toys are where all the
money is overall I gave the episode of B
minus I mean it had good moral
through-line about sticking to the path
and working together as a team I did
feel like they were doing Zeb's
character disservice by making him so
quick to open up to a kid Ezra that is
he's younger than Luke whenever he
boarded the Millennium Falcon an episode
for young children who hang out with
adults mostly in cartoons tend to fall
into a couple of categories they're
either like a bart simpson character who
gets into mischief all the time like
Aladdin I know everyone is calling Ezra
space Aladdin or they're like a mate
Griffin and they become the butt of
everyone's jokes I don't think that
Ezra's meg and I do like the direction
they're taking his character but I don't
like it as much when they lean really
hard on the bart simpson stuff like for
instance stealing the heads off of
stormtroopers and pranking Zeb who I
guess in this analogy would be like Moe
the bartender that just wanted to think
about Zeb is moe I am really excited to
see more the Inquisitor though who I
think is coming back in episode 4 next
week so since monday nights are like my
Gotham night and I'm usually working on
those videos i'll be posting Star Wars
rebels videos on Tuesdays so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I know
everyone was wondering when I was going
to post this but basically Tuesday's is
when that's going to happen there is a
lot going on this week there's a new
Legend of Korra game that i'll be
streaming on my game channel so be sure
to check the description for links to
that there's also some really big game
of thrones news if you guys are big game
of Thrones fans right now though you can
click here for my rebels episode 2 video
and you can click here to catch up on
Legend of Korra thank you so much for
watching now it's all high five and I'll
see you for some Korra streaming later